what was the big lesson for banks in
this year's stress tests it could be
this take your best swing Fed doesn't
mind if you miss that's what we learned
from Goldman Sachs JP Morgan and Morgan
Stanley here to explain and discuss or
gamma Scouse key managing partner at
autonomous research and his colleague
Brian 4am between them they cover large
midsize consumer and regional banks and
credit card companies here in America
it's a long list gentlemen welcome while
I agree that that is the biggest
surprise these three banks Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan Morgan Stanley all submitted
to the Fed a request to return capital
raised dividends buy back stock we're
told no that's too aggressive you gotta
dial it back but they got as much as
they could in theory exactly and I think
that that's what you want to say I I
wouldn't have to bent out of shape about
the Mulligan taking the Mulligan as a
stigma because what investors really
want to see is that the banks within
reason are asking for as much capital
return as they can get and the process
is designed to allow for that then it's
not a stigma it's just like any other
negotiation you ask for too much and you
find your way in the middle I think
that's right and I mean if you look at
prior years the big difference is the
Mulligan versus the qualitative fails so
the qualitative fails in past years shut
off your dividends and buy back for six
or nine months go spend 100 million
dollars on a new tech system it was
pretty painful the Mulligan is you know
I asked for four billion of trucks
redemptions and I only get three billion
it's just kind of a negotiation I was on
the call yesterday that senior fed
officials held with reporters and asked
explicitly does the Fed view this
Mulligan right the resubmission with any
prejudice and was told no on the
contrary there's absolutely nothing
wrong with it so I'd have to him it
makes me wonder why goldman sachs is the
only firm to have figure this out two
years in a row and why other bank CEOs
haven't been more aggressive with their
capital requests because if i were a
shareholder that's what i'd be wanting
them to do you're right like everybody
should be resubmitting yes but I think
that there is a caveat to that which is
that if you ask for aggressively too
much
then I think you could be viewed as
being somewhat reckless mmm there's a
fine line that's right I said what does
it dance yeah they don't want people
shooting for the moon they want this as
a genuine difference of opinion where
you round it to 5.1 and they round it to
4.9 on your stress minimum rather than
really ding you just kind of fix the
problem so would you expect to see more
banks resubmitting next year on the
basis of what we've learned these past
two years the obvious lesson would be to
do that mmm with again within reason
right and what's your take away the
stress tests are done what's your number
one feeling about all of it well I think
one of the most important takeaways is
that when all is said and done
especially for the banks that are not
the very very big as that are
systemically important the capital
return that they're being allowed to
give back dividends and buybacks is kind
of creeping forward and we're getting to
the point where banks are going to
retake their place at the table as among
the very largest the producers of
dividends for investors I dekha that I
mean maybe a couple numbers to frame it
the average payout ratio for the banks
would cover seventy-two percent the
consensus coming in with 65 and the 25
year average is 75 so a little bit
better than the consensus was looking
for and actually within spitting
distance of kind of what we all fought
was normal 10 to 15 years ago explain to
everybody what the payout ratio is yeah
so it's just the total dividends plus
five acts / your earnings so generally
if you're thinking about a company in
steady state and you're a bank you're
growing your balance sheet kind of
modestly four or five percent a year you
should be able to pay out seventy or
eighty percent your earnings and keep
your capital ratios but as we see here
card companies are being given the
go-ahead the green light to return a
great deal of capital relative to
earnings the big Wall Street banks are
still being penalized why I think this
is the remaining rub the standard for
the big banks is legitimately higher
both in terms of the amount of capital
they have to hold and the process they
have to produce to show they're doing
the stress test right why are they being
effectively checked twice right they
have to hold more capital right we get
that right the belt and suspenders
approach whether it's on the leverage
ratio or the capital ratio that
Thanks have to have more capital the big
banks have to have more capital than the
small banks shouldn't that be enough
though if you've got lots of capital why
should you be restricted in what you're
able to return to shareholders out of
your excess I think we're still close to
the crisis when those are the banks that
needed bailouts or came very close to
needing bailouts and bailouts are
politically very very unpopular so
there's an element of politics here as
well all right let's stop being so nice
let's talk about the losers deutsche
bank and sun ton dare what does it mean
for them uh this was expected and it's
not the first time for Santa dare and
for Deutsche it was it was well expected
that they're gonna probably have to go
through a couple of cycles I think
before their US business is viewed as
having the controls in place but it
didn't really it really wasn't eligible
guy you evaluate me you don't rate
Deutsche Bank but you know the firm well
because it competes so directly with the
likes of Citigroup be of a ghola Morgan
Stanley JP Morgan etc in some of these
core investment banking and capital
markets businesses what does a failure
like that say about a Deutsche Bank I
think it says that they probably have to
pay a lot more attention to controls and
and systems that the Fed wants to see in
place for their their US businesses
doesn't mean they're poorly run here's
what i will say i will say that i think
that the non US banks have had a
tendency to view the US regulators as
secondary or tertiary and they have
played historically more by the rules of
their home market and what the Fed is
saying again and again is that if you
want to play in our capital markets in
the United States then you must play by
our rules except if you're one of these
banks like Deutsche Bank you make a ton
of your dough here in the United States
so shouldn't you pay attention to our
regulators I think more and more we're
gonna see that Brian if we look past the
big banks and their competitors like
Deutsche Bank for example into some of
the companies that you cover more
closely the Super Regionals for example
the card companies what are the biggest
lessons to take away from these tests
well I mean I think that it's your back
to normal on payout ratios right your
dividends are lower your buybacks are
bigger so there's a little bit of
mix difference but if I look at
companies like capital one or US bank or
they're they're kind of at normal levels
80s ninety percent payout ratios I think
the one who's kind of in one foot in the
other 11 foot one half the other foot
the other half is Wells Fargo right
that's always been the debate are they a
big mega bank because it got one point
seven trillion of assets that kind of
looks like a JP Morgan but if you look
at it there's just a really really big
version of PNC or US bank they're a lot
more plain vanilla than i would take JP
Morgan wouldn't you they are and you
kind of see that though in the results
so they got a payout ratio of about
seventy percent so they're not as high
as some of the other peers I reference
but they're higher than be of a city JP
Morgan if you look at the one wrinkle
though it's that the sea car and this is
true for a lot of banks not just wells
it's effectively their binding
constraint for capital so you've got all
this you know SLR ratios you've got
g-sibs you got a million fed
pronouncements and then oh by the way
none of that matters it's really see
card that's your limiting factor why is
it that the Fed seems to like the idea
of buybacks more than dividends
dividends I think are correctly viewed
by the Fed is much more of a commitment
right an ongoing command ongoing
commitment I think when a bank sends a
signal by stopping their dividend or
reducing their dividend that is viewed
historically as a much more important
signal do you think I'll see them relax
the rules and allow but David yeah ratio
to go up next year uh we think that we
detect that there's been a little bit of
that behind the scenes because several
the banks not the big mega banks but the
regionals have crept up into the above
thirty percent payout ratio space based
on their actions yesterday